[Música]
con nuestra segunda invitada del día así
seguimos hablando de la red social
Twitter y de los cambios que ya empezó a
realizar su nuevo dueño el
multimillonario y long Mask no polémico
en toda su llegada a esta red social
finalmente la adquirió y pues está el
mando saludamos a Elizabeth de Rivera Ya
sea directora de comunicaciones de icfes
de una red mundial de más de 100
organizaciones promotoras y defensoras
de la libertad de expresión y acceso a
la información También tenemos en
nuestra mesa de trabajo a Daniela
Blandón nuestra cronista de economía
también muy empapada el tema Twitter que
le hemos venido le hemos venido
conversando a Dani desde que pues
comenzó toda esta polémica de
adquisición por parte de elon muff se
acuerda que pues sí lo iba a comprar no
lo iba a comprar la demanda en de la web
al final terminó comprando a su manera a
regañadientes con toda esta imagen
icónica de que tenía el lavamanos y dijo
que pues sí que ya le iba a comprar
liberando el pájaro dijo que el pájaro
se había pues liberado Y bueno todas
estas medidas que ha empezado a tomar y
los Monster de su llegada a Twitter Dani
despidiendo y disolviendo toda la junta
directiva él siendo el sí o el único
digamos que en este momento por ahora
Toma las decisiones dijo que no iba a
ser digamos permanente sino que iba a
pues conformar una junta directiva no
sabemos si lo va a hacer no sabemos
cuándo también la polémica de lechek que
tienen estas personas políticos personas
importantes digamos dentro de la dentro
de la sociedad también que dijo ya no va
a ser gratis ya no va a ser un algo
burocrático como se hacía adentro sino
que el que quiera tener su cheque azul
Pues que pague 8 dólares mensuales Mejor
dicho el retorno de Trump que todavía
está bien entre dicho hay muchas cosas
para hablar y cascada también de
personajes que se han salido de Twitter
y que están anunciando que ya no van a
seguir en esta red social después de que
la comprara de este Magnate de los autos
de lujo y de los viajes al espacio y de
muchas otras empresas Así es mi año
saludamos Entonces ahora sí ya la
tenemos Elizabeth de Rivera nuestra
invitada para entonces hablar de todo lo
que está sucediendo con esta red social
Elizabeth Gracias por estar esta mañana
de jueves con nosotros en directo
América de Francia 24 para hablar
entonces de toda esta polémica
adquisición por parte del
multimillonario elon musk en la
actualidad como ve todo lo que está
ocurriendo y y no sé si podemos esforzar
un poco Hacia dónde vamos en el futuro
cercanísimo
Hola qué tal Muchísimas gracias por la
invitación pues si no ha sido de verdad
que esta compra pues ha puesto de
manifiesto los riesgos para los derechos
humanos y la seguridad personal cuando
una sola persona tiene el control
absoluto de las políticas que pueden
afectar a casi 400 millones de usuarios
no Y en este caso esta persona como bien
señalabas ha demostrado repetidamente
que que no entiende las realidades de la
gobernanza escala en una plataforma como
esta o sea como lo hemos visto Durante
los últimos días Esto empezó a
aparecerse más un circo no en cuestión
de horas most calavista de todos
presentó y y desdijo a este consejo de
moderación
compuesto por cierto por sus más
cercanos colaboradores de silicon Valley
Cuando levantó la suspensión de una
figura extrema derecha se había dicho
que primero este consejo de moderación
iba a tomar las decisiones y a las 3
horas ya estaba levantando sus pensiones
tuiteó una teoría la respiración en
respuesta al intento de asesinato del
líder de la cámara de diputados
americana donde resultó gravemente el
río su marido lanzó la idea de cobrar
los 20 dólares y luego a los minutos se
desdijo después de una de un intercambio
con el autor Stephen King y lo bajó 8
dólares llamo usuarios patrones y
campesinos se quejó de todos los de que
todos los odian O sea la verdad es que
este las palabras iría interesado han
aumentado en la plataforma ya está
haciendo todo esto monitoreado lo mismo
que la pornografía bueno Esto es lo que
se ha reportado solo en inglés O sea
imagínate que todavía no tenemos idea
del impacto de los recortes de empleados
y vaivenes de decisiones de elon en
otros países no y Bueno claro este justo
este tipo de Liderazgo estable y seguro
que que las marcas no quieren ver que
son sus principales que es Quiénes son
quién sustentan el negocio Y por
supuesto los usuarios activos que
proveen el contenido y que son gran
parte
artistas medios políticos activistas
pues es justamente lo que no quieren
Escuchar
Qué posibilidades entonces tiene Twitter
de supervivencia mirándolo en un mediano
y largo plazo teniendo en cuenta que
primero se quiere alejar de los
anunciantes que son los que le dan casi
el 90% de su caja y segundo que tantas
personas en vista de todos estos que
está sucediendo Se están yendo de la red
social entonces que que después Cómo se
va a financiar Twitter
es como una de las de las grandes
preguntas no y bueno también una de las
cosas que no hay que olvidar es que él o
no compró Twitter solo no
está el acuerdo incluye el holding del
príncipe saudí
una subsidiaria del gobierno soberano de
Qatar una bolsa de criptomonedas de
origen chino o sea ninguno de ellos
precisamente Baluarte de la libertad de
expresión ahora entonces habla por ahora
lo que se ve hasta arriba son las
decisiones de elon pero también hay que
tener ojo que va a pasar con estos
intereses que claramente tienen un
interés Al haber invertido junto con él
en la plataforma en Cómo se va a
desarrollar
personalmente creo que justo o sea antes
de de ver lo que sigue por ahora va a ir
empeorando hasta ver si mejora si es que
mejora no vamos vamos a ver creo que
todo todo Está muy en el aire y eso es
lo contiene a los usuarios tan nerviosos
buscando por ahí algunas migración a
otras plataformas o sea se ha llamado de
más todo en por ejemplo una de ellas
pero creo que hay que tener los ojos muy
abiertos no solo a las decisiones de él
sino lo que está detrás de cámaras eso
le quería preguntar Elizabeth ante todo
este panorama que todavía no es cierto
porque acaba de llegar y los mozo a la
cabeza de Twitter podría otra red social
realmente competir con este gigante
Pues por eh es difícil verlo ahora
porque es como un círculo
vicioso donde uno quiere estar donde sus
audiencias están en este momento como lo
decíamos la mayor parte de los usuarios
que generan el contenido de calidad en
Twitter son periodistas medios
activistas políticos O sea la red social
Twitter en específico A diferencia de
otras se categoriza por eso si estos
grupos se mueven a otro lado bueno se
moverá la conversación última los dos
últimos días he visto por ejemplo grupos
de académicos moviéndose bastante a esta
red social que mencionaba más todo pero
hay que ver si la migración llega a ser
tan importante o no
y eso también tiene que ver con el
movimiento no solo de las audiencias
sino de los grupos
que conforman esto es estas
conversaciones